Hey Youtubers happy holidays.
So we just learned a whole bunch of stuff
about Avengers infinity war.
They did a big info dump about all these characters
they're including, so is gonna be a breakdown
as well as some info on the changes they're
making the peoples back stories.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
going on now to all you have to do to enters
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything during the
break.
So we all learned that Avengers infinity war
is going to be shooting principal photography
with all the actors starting in January associate
is getting real and they finally revealed
a cast list of the characters are going to
appear another always like a few minor characters
they just don't include on their.
This can be like 60+ big name characters total
a lot of those will be in background shots,
in addition to the main actors that are going
to be the ones that you see most of the time
on screen so the big surprises.
Or maybe not big surprises are that they confirm
the guardians Captain Marvel and they did
not put Spider-Man on the list, so everyone's
freaking out, wait a minute.
Does this mean the Spider-Man is not to be
in infinity war no that's just because it's
a separate deal with Sony, they just have
to make terms for the financial arrangement
know how that's can work on the back and the
lawyers from Marvel and Sony have to do ThunderDome
to man enter one Spider-Man leave so Spider-Man
will be a part of infinity war is is that
they need to haggle over all the minor details.
So don't worry about that the Russo's have
already said that he is coming back in infinity
war he'll have some suit upgrades.
They will do all of the Spider-Man things.
Don't worry, we'll talk about that in the
second the other big surprise is that there
changing Captain Marvel's origin story.
They board he kind of explain that Lycos Kevin
fight he and the person that's writing the
script for the solo Captain Marvel movie had
just said that her origin story, the classic
one just reads too much like Green Lantern
in there just so many reasons why they do
not want you to associate Captain Marvel with
Green Lantern you a little in that movie bond
two they want you to be thinking about Marvel
stuff not DC stuff when you go see a Marvel
movie.
So they just debuted a new Captain Marvel
comic where they tease the change in her origin
story.
They were very nebulous about like very ambiguous.
This was like white light enveloping her talking
about inheriting all these wondrous powers
from a different peoples planet, she's talking
about the Cree.
So she doesn't exactly reference the artifact
that gave her powers like the original thing
that gave her her powers was an exploding
psyche magnetron which was a Cree weapon.
Now, it sounds like it's going to be something
it's a little bit different and there is no
reference of Captain Mar-Vell the original
Captain Marvel you can kind of see what they're
doing the like slowly moving away from Green
Lantern type stuff but trying not to change
her origin that much so in the movies I feel
like were all in the same page when were like
yet they're probably going to give her an
infinity gem if that's where her powers will
come from.
So that she is just as powerful is scarlet
which because right now vision and scarlet
which are the most OP characters on the avengers.
We don't know the full extent of scarlet which
is powers that they continually of all.
So they were kind of like the whole's powers
like he just get stronger and stronger the
matter he gets so scarlet which just gets
more and more powerful the more she learns
to use her abilities so background, comic
con when Kevin fight he announced Brie Larson's
Captain Marvel.
He was saying she's going to be the most OP
of avengers hero character they've ever introduced
into a movie.
So he wasn't necessarily saying that she's
more powerful that they Thanos because there
changing a bunch of the comic book characters
for the movies they're also gonna change Thanos,
just a little bit but I think that he's just
going to be OP enough that he can hand the
avengers their asses and make the whole herd.
So don't expect them to say exactly how powerful
everyone is like the neck in a put a number
on or anything like that even Elizabeth Olson
explained that when she was working with the
Russo's and Joss Weeden to create her scarlet
which character we were very ambiguous about
what her powers were like one of the big things
that Joss Weeden did with her when they were
first working on the character was figure
out the hand movements that she did like she
almost looks like she's weaving spells, but
that's not really how her powers in the movies
work she doesn't have her chaos magic like
she does in the comics with the big difference
when she got to Captain America Civil War
is if he's supposed to be way more powerful,
but the thing is is, she said the Russo's
have Apsley no idea what to do with her powers
they were like we don't really understand
the full extent of your powers which it sounds
mind blowing that the directors wouldn't know
exactly how her character works.
So it just sounds like they're building themselves
room to change their minds down the road.
Like when they're making infinity war if they
want scarlet which to be able to do something.
This is completely outlandish and overpowered
they shall be able to do that.
So I understand if you're little frustrated
with them not like completely nailing down
what these characters can do it just the way
that movies get made is like Batman fighting
Superman is there's always like these leaps
in logic.
You have to make like why would Batman be
able to get the upper hand on Superman of
Superman is superfast is the just not that
smart is just not paying attention like he
was at the find ways to explain the logic,
but what about the Thanos what about his powers.
I think the really fun thing that nobody's
really been talking about that much is what
are they going to change about the Thanos
like what we can a see him do because the
whole point of infinity war is that the Thanos
is one person he does have an army behind
him but he will be able to defeat the avengers
by himself but how is he going to do that
like what is he gonna do to defeat the whole
someone who is arguably him and kill a bull
Thanos has very powerful energy blasts physically
he's very strong to, so he could beat the
crap out of the hole but the hulk would recover
very quickly and just bounce right back even
stronger as he gets matter so just expect
Thanos to be very resistant to physical damage
and mental damage like the big thing in Asia
old Tron is that scarlet which puts the way
and the on the avengers and kind of turns
them against each other.
She's able to control the hoax mind so I wouldn't
be surprised if she's not able to do that,
that they Thanos next on the list.
Spider-Man was going on the Spider-Man powers
in infinity war will he's not can change that
much will probably get a cooler suit they'll
have some extra abilities little more Stark
tech little more hardcore for fighting people
like the Thanos.
I wouldn't be surprised if he gets like a
little bit closer to comic book iron spider,
but the whole thing about Spider-Man in Civil
War was that he was like this little kid experiencing
this giant compline like oh my God this is
so crazy and I have school on Monday that's
going to be the same deal in infinity war
he'll still be in high school will still be
a kid.
Tony Stark will still treat him like a kid.
So like the go pick Spider-Man up go fight
the Thanos and then Tony will go drop them
off for school the next day, so Spider-Man
really brings the little kids perspective
to this big Galactic universe changing story
that's the whole reason for him being there
in an obviously he's probably going to out
quip Thanos.
That's probably going to be one of the funniest
things to come out of the movie watching.
Spider-Man try to out quit Thanos and we haven't
heard a whole lot of Thanos puns, but just
imagine Darth Vader puns in Rogue one only
coming out of Thanos's mouth.
Be careful not to choke on your own ambitions
Peter Parker and speaking of quips what about
the guardians to, so we pretty much have the
main guardians roster with the addition of
nebula, so nebula supposed to be in infinity
war, which I think is great because Karen
Guillen's awesome and I can't wait to see
what they do with her character in guardians
to we won't even have to wait that long to
find out because guardians is coming out in
the spring.
So the thing about guardians is the James
Gunn's been so funny when he's talked about
how his films fit into the main Marvel continuity
is probably joking when he says this, but
he said things like will you in order not
to worry about the main continuity because
I'm in a different universe like the guardians
are not in the same universe as the other
Marvel characters so he said that in a really
offhanded way.
I do not think that the guardians are in a
different universe.
I think the just in a different part of the
universe that so far away that they don't
necessarily need to reference everything that's
going on on earth the connective tissue for
bringing them closer to earth space is the
Thor movies because stores the Earth-based
avenger, but it's also kind of a space-based
movie because Asgard is in a different place
in outer space.
So the last big puzzle piece is obviously
Doctor strange, most of you probably knew
that he was going to show up in infinity war
there can have all kinds of fun pairing them
off with the other avengers characters the
Thor teaser at the end of Doctor strange was
just a taste for that.
Just imagine how his personality will work
with someone like Robert Downey Junior on
screen.
It'll be crazy, but a lot of you have asked
about where the infinity gems are wears the
soul.
Jim it's the only one that's missing now will
probably get a taste for that in the Thor
movie.
It'll either be inside someone else like Heimdal
Wardell be inside somewhere else likes the
car because they tease the planet Hulk storyline
the planets the car has the old power so there's
a number of different comic book concepts
that they can use in co-op for soul Jim purposes.
Do not forget that vision still has the mind
gem in his four head.
Somehow they Thanos is going to have to rip
that out to put in the infinity gauntlet and
then you have him collecting all the other
gems.
So really Thor Ragnarok is probably going
to be the first taste we get for him assembling
gems in the goblet like do not be surprised
if he puts at least one gem in the goblet
at the end of that movie that I know we haven't
talked a lot about Black Panther.
So there's just so much about that movie that
we haven't learned yet.
So what can happen is is that they'll be in
production next year or so will probably learn
all kinds of stuff about Black Panther as
they're rolling out guardians Spider-Man in
Thor Ragnarok.
That's right there can be so many Marvel movies
next year it is going to be amazing and that
says nothing about the new Star Wars episode
eight film or the DC films like wonder woman
the Justice league really like 20 17th is
seeming so much better than 2016.
Right now I cannot wait to see everything,
but let me know in the comments which new
character are you most excited about in infinity
war seeing Spider-Man with all the avengers
on screen again.
Meeting Captain Marvel for the first time
or just seeing Thanos hand every single avenger
their asses as he assembles the gauntlet just
like he did in the comics.
I will say congratulations to this week's
Spider-Man giveaway winner Candace Simmons
you an Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back and my channels and
get your contact details.
There is a new round that starts now in this
video just announce the winner the next time
I post a Marvel video I will be doing some
Christmas themed comic book videos this week
like Spider-Man saves Christmas Be sure to
leave Santa some extra ammo underneath the
tree with all the milk and cookies if there
are any like special Christmas style, comic
book videos the you guys want me to do or
special stories just let me know in the comments
there will be all kinds of stuff happening
this weekend so happy holidays everybody,
new Marvel and DC coming real soon while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for my breakdown of the Darth Vader WTF scenes
in Rogue one and you can click here to learn
all about the Justice league teaser they just
dropped thank you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys tonight!